大家午安
大家好
吃飽沒
好久沒開直播了
我現在在線上
請大家幫我分享這個直播
讓其他人也能夠知道這個好消息 好嗎
跟大家說我最近的一個消息
我和知識衛星合作開了一堂線上課程
名字叫做生活中醫養生課
今天我的直播預計會開大概一個小時
小編跟我說有粉絲留言提問
他說想知道線上課程到底怎麼買
還有的人說不了解線上課程到底是什麼
想下載這個檔案來看嗎
還是要下載嗎
還是說怎麼樣做
我現在就來跟你說明
今天直播的主題是要教大家購買線上課程
如果留言問病症的話 抱歉
因為線上沒辦法問症
我也不能夠回答這有關病症的問題
我們不是有好多影片在YT頻道和FB
那這堂線上課程
和胡乃文開講的頻道影片有什麼不同
我看YT和FB就好了
不用看線上課程也OK吧
如果我的影片對你有幫助
我就很感謝你能夠開心的收看我們的影片
在胡乃文講這個頻道裡面
我已經製作了差不多200多支的影片
而每一支影片大概的時間是12分鐘長度
但是你知道嗎
就是因為時間的長度就規定在那麼短的時間裡面
這樣子的話呢
節目
觀看節目的群眾還真的不知道怎麼看
而且還有一點
在這個所有的節目當中呢
因為那個頻道的關係
它還有一個所謂的演算的規則
因此在YT上面或者在FB上面
比較沒有辦法完整的
有系統的來學習所謂的健康養生之道
如果你想要搜尋的話
也要自己去搜尋
但是線上課程就不一樣囉
它是有一個章節
有一個目錄的這個部分
所以你可以每一章節
每一支影片
你想一集一集的有序來看
或者你想挑著看哪一個
而且這樣子的話
都能夠很棒的在這個地方來收集到
或者來看我的所有的內容
胡醫師
那這堂生活中醫養生課內容有多棒
誰適合看這堂課
其實我每次都被人問這個
我說那你是我的學生當然都可以對不對
可是呢
你說我年紀很大或年紀很輕
可不可以
只要你有興趣
你都可以來看我的節目
那我的這個生活中醫養生課呢
會教給你如何調理身體的這個體質啊
還有自己檢視自己的身體訊號啦
以及教你辨識所謂肝心脾肺腎
到底哪個地方健康哪個地方不健康
還有呢
你遇到緊急的狀況的時候
自己如何來救自己的一命
不但如此
學會這堂課你還會幫助身邊的家人
因此呢
你可以告訴
我可以告訴你說
你的阿公阿嬤
你的爸爸媽媽
你自己還有你的小孩
只要他的年紀
就是他已經
他的學問
他的學識程度呢
大概有小學以上
大概都可以來跟
只要他有興趣
當然了
小孩子有的時候
他有興趣
但是他不一定能夠看得懂
那也不要緊
那個父母都可以告訴他
還有就是
我們剛講了
遇到緊急情況的時候
可以救自己一命
不但如此
而且呢
學了這堂課以後啊
你還能夠幫助你身邊的家人
課程包括了長期的調理啊
還有短期見效的那些個方法呀
以及緊急自救
這三個方向
想要長期或
短期一起急救的人
就是長期調理啊
或者短期見效的
或者是急救的人
都可以來學這堂課
這堂課就很適合於
現在觀看節目的你
還有呢
你如果是正在職場上打拼的人
除了買一些簡報課啊
商業課啊等等
健康方面能不能呢
當然了
它非常適合於你啊
擁有健康的身體
身體才能夠讓你在職場上
發揮得更好
投資健康
讓你賺得最大
是不是
這堂課我也會教你
很多穴位的按摩啊
那你會問
在YT影片上面
不是也已經有講到穴位嗎
對啊
我有講穴位
但是那些時間呢
因為就是說有限制對不對
我就沒有辦法把每個穴位
都親自的示範給你看
對不對
那但是我現在這堂
線上課程的話呢
有個最大的好處
就是能夠解決了這個
你不能夠很系統的學習的
這一個問題
我的這堂課
它其中介紹了三十個以上
有效的很棒的穴位
我們知道中醫的穴位啊
我們講正經穴位就三百六十多個
這麼多的穴位
哪幾個比較重要啊
在學針灸的人都知道
什麼武術穴的什麼
但是我告訴你
這些非常重要
可是你不是專業的嘛
你只是來學習一點點
自己保養自己的話
那麼我這裡面的
這三十幾個穴道呢
就很棒的
能夠幫你從頭到腳
都能夠學習到
然後怎麼去按
怎麼去壓
而且我還是在這裡面
親自示範
教給你怎麼樣去找位置
怎麼樣去按摩
怎麼樣去拍打
這樣子
你就不必費很多力氣去學
並且達到最好的止痛
或者是疏通筋絡效果
是不是
你以為就這樣
不是的
在這堂課程裡頭
還會幫助你整理一個
穴位總複習
例如你突然的
說肚子脹了
或者是突然頭痛了
或者你在線上課程能夠
但是呢
你只要遇到了這些
你在我的這個線上課程裡頭
就能夠快速地
找到對症治療的
幾個穴位了
不論你在家
或者在辦公室
或者出差
如果你的身體不舒服
或者沒辦法
立刻就去看醫生的話
那麼你就直接上線上來查
我講的就是穴位
這樣子的話呢
就能夠當時
就也許能夠幫助你
緩解了那個病痛
我還記得我在以前
就有過朋友打電話問我
我現在該怎麼辦
我馬上告訴他一下子
他就行了
這就也就是說
我這個課程
就有點像你在生活中的一個
養生百寶箱
還有呢
我還給你們準備了
非常好做又方便的
食療茶飲
吃的喝的
每個人的體質不同
所以我特別調整了
食療的這個裡頭的
重要的比例
大部分呢是
滋養身體的食材
這些食材哪裡買呢
你到菜市場或超市
都可能買得到
或者說你也可以到藥房去買
這也是行的
讓你在每天的這個餐桌上
煮一個很美味的料理
就能夠幫助你
獲得營養與健康
不是很棒嗎
最棒的一件事情
就是我
請我的水某(老婆)
親自示範
他會親自示範
五道食療的詳細做法
還有十四道
因為他完成的成品
就是已經做好了的
還有把食譜啊
份量
他這個食譜裡頭的份量啊
誰適合吃啊
誰不適合吃啊
都提供給你
我想這樣子很能幫助你
如果你是因為很忙
沒辦法自己開夥的人
我就想你
也都幫你想到了
就可以怎麼樣
不用開夥
就用電鍋來煮一煮吧
對不對
用電鍋來煮
這樣子的食療呢
電鍋都沒有的人
我就只好教你沖泡茶飲了
對不對
那就只能夠這樣
不論你是在家
或者在辦公室
都能夠享用這些
而且對你的健康
都有很大的幫助
是不是
胡醫師
最近有國外的粉絲在問啊
說線上課程的內容
以後會不會放在頻道裡面
這個問題我想
大概也有很多人想要知道
不是只有你一個人
線上課程的內容呢
以後不會在胡乃文開講頻道裡面放映
因為這是付費的內容
我們花了很多的成本
來投入這個製作
海外的朋友
如果你有興趣的話
歡迎你購買我的線上課程
越早買
價格就越優惠
這很好
在線上看
直播的各位朋友
你想要買課程的話
現在輸入我這個直播的
專屬折扣碼
還可以直接扣掉
300元
哇 能便宜就便宜買
就是現在課程呢
是3690元
輸入折扣碼以後
可以直接扣掉三百塊
購買線上課程
你就只要購買這個線上課程
你只要花3660元就可以了
這個是什麼東西呢
你看
就這裡
huliVe
hu是我的姓嘛對不對
live是生活的意思
胡乃文中醫養生
中醫生活養生
然後加個300
就是扣300元的意思
很好
很好記
huiive300
這個是你的直屬的折扣碼
胡醫師
那還有粉絲詢問說
購買線上課程
以後要怎麼看
有需要把檔案下載下來嗎
有沒有觀看期限呢
你購買了線上課程之後
不必要下載檔案
只要用你的手機
或者電腦都可以
進入知識衛星的網站
然後輸入你的帳號密碼
那樣子呢
你就能看到課程的內容了
你可以重複觀看
也沒有時間的限制
也沒有限制你只能看幾次
不是
隨時隨地都能上線觀看
所以你假如說在捷運上面
或者是在辦公室裡面
突然的
現在是並不很忙的話
你都可以看
你看這是很方便的
對不對
好
除了剛剛講
誰適合購買這堂課之外
還有這一類人
很適合購買我的這堂養生課
那就是租屋在外面
無法就近照顧父母的人
你可以買一套這樣的課程
送給你自己的爸爸媽媽
如果你的爸爸媽媽
不知道怎麼操作
那你下次回家的時候
就教他怎麼樣上線
就觀看嘛
讓他們平常
可以保養身體健康
同時他們也會覺得
很開心很欣慰
你還會關心他們的健康
是不是
好
胡醫師那現在我們來示範購買流程
購買流程
好的
看
這個地方
你可以這樣子購買
你就上網了以後
你看
在這個地方
教給你說
就是點擊註冊
就這麼簡單
就點擊註冊了
註冊以後呢
再來就是
註冊之後
你就第二個
選擇註冊的方式
你有的人呢
喜歡用手機註冊
對不對
有的人用手機註冊
有的人呢
可以用email帳號
也就是你的電子郵件帳號
來 這分為這兩個
然後呢
就點擊所謂的立即註冊
就趕快的註冊就是了
然後再來
第四
點擊登入
然後點登入
登入了以後呢
再來就是
依照註冊的方式
選擇登入的方式
用電子郵箱
或者是你的
胡醫師我們立起來
哦這樣
給觀眾看
讓觀眾看得清楚
好
然後再來
再來第六個呢
就是確認已經登入
然後呢
在這個地方看到
特別重要的立即購買
就是了
然後點擊立即購買了以後
就可以了
再來看
選擇付款的方式
付款的方式呢
你看
有信用卡的
有信用卡一次
或者是分期
或者是到ATM去轉帳
有的人啊
他說我連這些東西都不會
那很簡單
就是去超商繳費
這是最簡單的話
到7-11啊
或者到這個
到Family Mart全家之類
這超商繳費
然後填寫購買的資訊
有聯絡的方式
跟聯絡的信箱
以及聯絡電話等等
這樣點擊
然後呢
胡醫師我們那個
拿起來一點
這樣子
好
這樣觀眾比較看得到
再下來就是
輸入折價券的代碼
然後點選套用
這就是剛剛看到的
hulive300對不對
同樣再來是點選確認購買
這樣子就完成了
註冊以及購買的手續
對
那現在我們來請小編講一下
來為大家示範一下
怎麼在電腦上購買
如果要是在
各位朋友在看那個
購買的過程
不太清楚的話
我們這邊來做一個
實際的操作示範
那首先第一個
大家點到我們的課程連結之後
我們在右上角這邊
會有一個註冊的按鈕
請大家幫我按下去之後呢
這邊就可以輸入你的電子信箱
那這邊的話
如果你有電子信箱的話
我們就可以先用
電子信箱來去做註冊
那在這邊去輸入你的密碼
之後的話
再輸入一次
我們就可以按立即註冊
完成註冊囉
那或者是說
你們有電子信箱的話
我們可以透過手機號碼
這邊來去做一個註冊
那我這邊打上
我的手機號碼之後呢
這邊再幫我按取得驗證碼
這樣到時候的話
你的手機就會收到
驗證碼的簡訊
那再請幫我把
驗證碼打上去之後
在這邊再去輸入
相關的你的密碼
你的密碼等等的內容之後
電子信箱這邊可以填
可以不填
那註冊完之後
請幫我按
立即註冊的按鈕
那這樣的話
你就可以完成註冊囉
OK
那你這邊完成註冊之後
我們再回到
我們的課程的頁面上面
我們在首頁這邊的話
就可以看到
胡乃文的生活中醫養生課
我們把他點進去
點進去之後呢
再請大家幫我按一下
登錄的按鈕
那這邊的話
就是請大家幫我去輸入
你的電子信箱跟你的密碼
或者是說
你本身自己就有
Google或Facebook
或是Apple的帳號的話
我們也可以用
不同的方式來做登錄
那假設說
我這邊先用
Google的帳號來去登錄
好
那登錄之後的話
大家就可以開始
準備做購買的動作
那要怎麼購買呢
我們先把頁面滑下去
滑下去之後的話
你可以看到在右邊
這邊會有一個
我們限時優惠的說明欄
那請各位同學們
我們就是按下
立即購買的按鈕
按下去稍等他一下之後
就會到我們的
結帳的頁面
那第一步的話
要請大家在付款方式這邊
幫我們選擇
你希望做進行的付款方式
就像剛剛胡醫師提到
有一次的信用卡付清
或是分期
或是你也可以用ATM
做帳號的轉帳
或是說你也可以
就用超商繳費
用最簡單的
去超商繳費的方式
來去做購買
好
那這邊的話
發票的資料的話
如果要是你本身
沒有特別的需求
我們就是直接用
他原本設定好的
電子發票
跟會員載具就可以了
那最後聯絡方式這邊
如果要是你有填會員資料的話
它就會自動的跑出來
那沒有的話沒關係
就麻煩你打上你的姓名
聯絡電話
跟你的聯絡信箱
那到時候我們這些通知
也都會寄到這些
你的聯絡資訊內
好
那接下來的話
這一步很重要
因為就是我們要來
輸入我們的折價券
所以就要請大家
在這邊有看到一個
使用折價券
幫我點進去之後呢
輸入我們今天給大家的
一個專屬優惠碼
就是hulive300
那這個的話
我們等一下資訊
也會貼在我們的留言處
再請大家可以
直接用這一組的
折價券來做使用喔
那這邊輸入完之後
請幫我按下套用
那套用之後的話
這邊就會顯示說
已經有折扣300塊錢了
那這樣的話
我們就可以繼續往下一步
按確認購買進行
好
那假設說
假設說你是用像信用卡付款的話
你會到一個金流的網站
那這邊就麻煩你
再幫我把付款的資訊給打進去
打進去之後呢
這邊做勾選
確認你的付款資訊正確
按下同意服務條款
確認送出
那這樣的話就是購買完成
那購買完成的話
你在email或是說
你簡訊這邊的話
就會收到相關的通知
那就這樣的話
就表示完成購買
那到時候我們開課的話
也會通知大家
大家就可以來去做
課程的收看喔
好
那以上的話就是
課程教學的內容
好
那胡醫師
現在要問你一個問題
是
如果粉絲不住在臺灣的話
怎麼辦
他可以買嗎
不住在臺灣也一樣
你只要是跟在國內買
都是完全一樣的
你怎麼買呢
就是上網
叫做 sat.cool/course/64
「知識衛星」網站
上知識衛星網站
上資訊網站
知識衛星
上知識衛星網站
你就可以購買了
如果你很想購買
那不太會在網上買
也不要緊
在海外
都是完全一樣的方式
假如在國外
他用什麼樣的方法買
只有用信用卡嗎
那詳細的就是
海外的一些購買資訊的話
包含大家會用不同的
像是VISA或是MASTERCARD
這些信用卡的種類
那我們這邊都有詳細的一些說明
那我這邊的話
會在留言處貼上
我們海外朋友
如何購買的一些說明欄
那就請大家可以到我們留言處
這邊來去做確認喔
謝謝
然後還是記得
把這一個
這一個叫做優惠的
專屬折扣碼
叫做hulive300
這樣子可以得到
300元的優惠
好 繼續下來呢
我們就講
我看到有一些觀眾留言
非常歡喜
有那麼多的觀眾會留言給我們
就是想要知道
我們這個課程的一些訊息
那我在這裡看到了一些訊息呢
就是有一位他問我
他說我們這個
就上完了這個課以後
是會變成自己的家庭醫生嗎
當醫生很難
當自己的家庭醫生很容易
你只要會呼呼的
這也是一個當醫生的方法
對不對
他有燒了
然後你說拿一個冰枕
讓他涼一涼也可以
但是我在課程裡頭
他有教給你
如何來做這個
讓發燒能夠很快降下去
而不需要受到其他的痛苦
也不需要吃藥
也不需要打針
能夠很快改善
那當然了
假如真的不行
還是找醫生這樣子
那有人就問
焦慮症可不可以治
這個地方很抱歉
我們在這個課程裡面呢
並沒有想要在這個線上來問
就是來給問一下
焦慮症是可以用
可以治的
在我們的課程裡頭
也有提到
如何來治這個焦慮這些東西
那當然了
你假如想要的話
你就上
在上網去
就是說買了這個課程
來看一看到底怎麼做
我這裡看看
還有沒有其他的一些問題
來請幫我看看
怎麼查
是有人問說
這個直播有多長時間
現在我這個直播的時間
只有一個小時
現在的時間呢
已經是12點53分了
也就是我們差不多
播了半個小時左右了
假如說你有朋友
你也可以現在就讓他上來
看我們的節目
然後我在這個地方
會給大家一些
需要了解的一些資訊
假如你有任何問題
你也可以就是
就是直接這個
在網路上面問
那剛才不是有人問說
什麼焦慮症或什麼
其實我在我的課程裡頭
很多的問題都有這個
都有解答
還有沒有什麼問的東西
我剛剛看到
我為什麼會開這堂課的道理
就是說我在一開始的時候
我就覺得
我用這個開講那個課程
也就是YT的頻道
跟Facebook的頻道
我在開這個課的時候
每一次講的東西
都是很分散的
例如我這一次
我講一個發燒
下次講一個
根本就與防燒完全無關的
另外一個也許是憂慮
也許是什麼東西
對不對
所以呢
這樣子一種
很沒有系統來看這個課程的
還有就是
你要上網去找的時候
你去搜尋
也許搜尋很久
因為那個題目跟這個內容
可能有點
就題目是講這個東西
但是內容裡頭
又有一些什麼這個吃的
那個吃的
你可能你根本就
沒辦法搜尋得到
是不是
不容易搜尋
所以呢
我現在開這個課程
就是告訴你說
我在這個課程裡頭
有很系統的
每一件事情講清楚
而且裡頭
就幾乎是每一個裡頭
都一定有針灸
按摩
以及吃什麼樣的東西
這些的方式
所以呢
我想應該可以
用這樣的方式去搜尋
反而更快
就是在課程裡面搜尋課程
課程裡面搜尋
想要知道的一些知識
好
胡醫師你在問大家說
大家有沒有什麼
一些訂購上的問題
可以留言
現在可以留言給我們
好
大家有沒有什麼樣的
這個
就是有關訂購上的問題
都可以留言給我們
我的小編很好
他們都非常津津業業的
非常專業的在這裡
給大家做這些答覆
因為你購買這些東西
就是說
你等於一面又支持我們
一面又支持你自己身體的健康
又支持你的家庭的身體健康
這樣是最好的一種
就是雙贏三贏的一個
一個一個現象是不是
對
感謝一下
購買的人
是
那最後呢
我也很感謝
已經購買的朋友
我的課程會在12月14日
要記
2月14是情人節
12月14就是了
在知識衛星的平臺上
這個上線
到時候呢
你就可以觀察
就是可以觀看這個課程了
還沒有購買的朋友呢
可以在今天
把握優惠的這個時間來下單
如果你在購買上
還有任何其他的問題
都歡迎私訊我們
我們的客服團隊呢
會幫助大家解答
也歡迎把今天的直播
分享給需要的朋友
感謝大家
我想啊
為什麼我們來這裡
做這個節目呢
我最後還想跟大家
多談一下
我行醫啊
已經超過35年了
我是在1984年
以後呢
就開始在這個
做中醫師
到現在呢
已經差不多35、36年
到38、39年了是吧
見證了生命的起落
也在各地呢
做
就是在紐約啦
在華盛頓DC啦
在舊金山啦
在美國很多的地方
以及在東南亞的
像是印尼啊
馬來西亞啦
還有新加坡等等
這些地方做演講
也受到很多的
這個
看到很多的那些
受到病痛
所折磨的人
跟他們相遇
每次見面的時候呢
他偶爾都會深深體會到
如果年輕的時候
就能夠懂得保養
懂得保護自己的健康
許多的痛苦和煎熬
都能夠避免
像我自己
大概也是在
差不多40歲左右
開始當中醫師
開始了解到
如何保養的時候
我也開始這樣保養
到現在呢
已經接近80歲的人了
那麼在這個時候呢
我也很想把這些經驗
就分享在這堂課裡頭
因此我開了這堂課以後呢
就幫助了年輕朋友
還有快要熟齡的你
或者是已經長期照顧
長期照顧家人
盡可能
不論是在家
或者利用日常的空檔
隨時隨地
都能夠
在我的線上課程中獲得
我所提供的這些養生的良方
把這堂課
當成一個禮物
送給你尊重的老師
你的前輩
或者我相信對他們
一定會有很好的幫助
對不對
他們一定能夠
感受到你的關心
在這堂課裡頭呢
我不但想傳授你
所謂的千年的中醫智慧
也能夠讓你
實際能夠應用到生活中
工作中
我更希望能夠
啟發你找到生命的真諦
並且能夠探索幸福的本質
胡醫師好
我們這邊的話
在YouTube上面
有一個同學有留言
想要詢問說
胡醫師你好
請問課程裡面
有包含什麼時候去做
穴位按摩最好
還有飯後可以馬上按
穴位按摩的這些
等等的內容嗎
其實什麼時候都可以做
只是要記住
中醫古時候的講法就是
大醉大飽
大疲勞
或者是
就是做了
或者大風大雨
等等的時候
就盡量不要做這些
可是呢
現在是一個平常時期
你剛剛吃過飯
暫時的不要做
但是呢
等過一些時間
過了差不多30分鐘
一個小時的時候
你再做按摩
都是可以的
而且我在這裡面所講的
這些按摩穴道
都是最簡單
而且幾乎是沒有害的那些穴道
那麼按了以後
只能夠讓你更好
可是我在這個課程裡頭
例如
有講到幾個穴道
例如止痛穴
或者是神門穴之類的
我就要求你
就是不要在晚上的時候來按
因為晚上按了以後
不但不能好睡
反而是會更有精神
這一類的講法
那這些呢
我在課程裡頭
都會說得很清楚
胡醫師現在課那個價錢
只到這一周而已
就是3960的這個價錢
是
只到這周
然後提醒大家說
下周一定會調漲價格
好
還有就是
剛才小編就特別提醒我
跟大家講一下
現在你要進來購買這個課程
現在這個時間是3960元
而且還有折扣價300元
可是下一周
這個價格就又要往上提
每一個星期
好像都往上面提一點點
然後到最後
我們的這個課程
它的這個大約是
11000元
也就是說
你越早購買越好
早鳥就能夠得到
早上的蟲來吃
那這個是最棒的事情
那當然了
每個人都希望做這個
Early Bird是不是
那不要到最後
當了這個Late Bird
到最後還沒有吃到就不好
那當然了
當然也希望
你花多一點錢來購買的話
對我來說我還更高興是不是
但是不要
我是希望大家都能夠
就是能夠用比較優惠的價格
購買到當個提早的鳥
那胡醫師有粉絲問說
這個課程可不可以在手機上觀看
剛才已經說過
它可以用手機
用iPad之類的平板
還也可以用你的電腦看
只要你的密碼是對的
你是用你的手機上去的
你就手機號碼登入
假如說你是用Email上去的
你就用Email的這個
account
Email帳號上去
那麼這樣子就可以了
只要密碼是對的
那沒有Email的話要怎麼辦
沒有Email
我想手機是有吧
用手機登入就可以購買了
對 用手機
手機可以看
手機也可以登入
Email帳號登入
那假如說你是用Email帳號登入的
你以後就是用Email帳號登入
你用手機登入的就手機登入
用手機是很方便的對不對
請胡醫師再講一下說
課程什麼時候可以開始看
因為我們現在是早鳥
請大家購買嘛
對 是的
好 這個剛才已經講過
這個早鳥可以先
就是得到優惠的價格
可是什麼時候開始看呢
12月24日
我記得的
對不起 12月14日
我一下子就多了一個月
12月14日
我還記得剛才講的
2月14日是情人節
12月14日
我們的課程開始
讓大家上網觀看了
謝謝已經購買的
我剛剛看到這個線上已經有人說
我購買了
對 我非常感謝你們購買了
這一個叫做生活中養生課
我在這裡面
把你的體質告訴你
你是什麼樣的體質
告訴你如何去按摩
或者拍打穴道
以及如何做食療
食療又分為茶飲的
有做藥膳的
假如說你這個時候
你說我沒有電鍋
沒有所有的廚具等等
那開水壺總有對不對
你就泡一個很好喝的養生茶來喝
那麼或者是你甚至於
用一個保溫杯
你把這些東西帶到辦公室裡面
都可以很好地來吃這些藥膳
這是我的生活中養生課
謝謝大家能夠購買我的課程
而且能夠看我的課程
並且更棒的就是
你能夠分享給別人
當你把好東西
分享給好朋友的時候
我相信對你的朋友來說是快樂
對自己也是一種
所謂的非常快樂的事情
那現在不知道還有沒有
還有沒有
我們在線上觀看的人
有什麼問題
可以在留言的地方留言
那我們可以看到了一個
因為我自己看這個
看電腦是不太方便
所以我請小編幫我們看
假如有
那我們馬上答覆
可是沒有的話呢
那我們就要跟大家說
Bye Bye
沒有了嗎
真的沒有了
好 拜拜
謝謝大家